[Music]
all right
in germany well actually in all the
world uh we are going back
into a lockdown they're calling it
winter 2020 or was it
coveted winter 2020 winter's coming a
sad
lonely winter that lonely winter yes and
in germany well i mean the whole world
here it seems like
all of europe we got a curfew now
perfume now yeah baby
did you guys see in south australia
you're not allowed to walk your dog or
exercise either that's how hard their
lockdown is really
no jogging no walking for how long i
don't know i think two weeks
yeah is demi there already no not yet
better curb some [ __ ] then because like
uh
i'm not even gonna act like this
affected
we were talking about that we're like
who the [ __ ] is up in the streets around
two
young people one after 10 though young
corona
is more potent it is it's the studies
study shows sometimes we do like we'll
end up staying up late because we're
watching something and we're like oh
[ __ ] we just realized we didn't have
dinner and it's like really late
damn it going up spreading the ronas no
no no no we just go to bed hungry i'm
saying that we don't get to order
because they're so you don't get to
receive the ronas from the postmates
since daylight savings ended i feel like
it's so
late at like 4 30. yes i'm like waiting
for bedtime i'm like is it bedtime yet
i get tired at nine now
yeah and i'm like oh [ __ ] it's way too
early for me to go to sleep i get tired
like 10 a.m sometimes like you get
excited like because you're up at 3am
guys it's gotta be bedtime now it's
seven
have you just tried to sleep when you're
tired and see what happens you knocked
the [ __ ] out maybe we're meant to sleep
10 hours
up at like four in the morning oh really
i gotta try it because
last night i was like fighting i was
like it's too early it's [ __ ] seven
oh [ __ ] seven [ __ ] well i only
slept four hours so that's why i was
tired
every single time i was tired i'd sleep
like at those strangers now
afternoon you do sleep with those
stretches yeah how many hours of sleep
you get in the night though
in a night like five or six hours no you
should go
you gotta get eight at least that's not
what we're supposed to do because that's
what dogs do right like dogs
you just see them knock out randomly
yeah they're just watching tv within
their outfit
you get nine hours every night because
what time you do okay you go to sleep
around
ten and you wake up at seven oh [ __ ]
that is of stuff
do you stay asleep or do you wake up uh
i don't wake up at all
he has no clue damn that's crazy i i
have a sleep seven hours
only when we end up going to sleep
really late like 12-ish you still wake
up at seven so that is less
my boy's narcoleptic like me that's
what's hard is that no matter what time
i go to bed i always wake up at seven
or right when the sun wakes up that's
when i wake up no i make up for the lack
of sleep
i can't i want to i slept at seven
i slept seven hours yesterday and then i
before that i slept eight
eight and a half and before that i slept
four are you checking your sleep or is
it your phone what is it
i track my sleep on my phone oh yeah how
does your phone know when you go to
sleep what if you pass out oh my gosh
i'm going to sleep and then i hit the
button and then i go like this
well you have a uh apple i have an aura
ring
oh this one's way cooler than the apple
watch yeah i actually wanted to get that
it tracks my heart rate variability my
rem sleep
what is that called the my aura ring or
oral ring i've never seen that sponsored
by or actually this doesn't really work
it does it does wait there's technology
in that pattern yeah yeah what the
[ __ ]
what kind of ring do you want and i was
like i want this [ __ ] ring look at
this ring guys
that's dope i want that ring too i
thought it was just a titanium ring
gives you like a sleep score it gives
you like your
your phases of sleep that's your
marriage ring that's my marriage ring
and it tells you like all your ideals
so she could track you though she's like
all right [ __ ] you're waterproof
yeah it is i can do everything with it
it's like why is his heart race
going up right now he's not working out
the nba players were using it in the
bubble and they would
it would use predictive measures based
off like your past temperatures and they
could see like
if when you're likely to get sick based
off your sleep so they can record
viruses kind of so i'm pretty much in
the nba pretty much cool
i'm in the nba which team uh
lakers yeah i think we're all going to
be wearing that next shoot it's so cool
do you keep it on when you're kickboxing
i keep on for everything you have to put
it on
your married finger no they say the
these are the most optimal
one two three i'm gonna put them on
either side these three fingers on
either side
yeah left or right i'm getting one do
they have cute colors do they come in
other sizes they have a one with a
diamond ring yeah i like how he's a rep
yeah bro i really love this what's the
cause
i'm saying off the record
how much do they go for it last question
uh this one was i think 300.
oh that's not bad it's not bad and it's
lifetime you have to pay like
cheaper than this ring but it's not as
good as mushroom king
mushroom get your mushroom king can i
can we get a mushroom ring yeah
while you're cooking your mushrooms with
your ring why don't you get a hat
because it's sunny it's very sunny very
sunny
[Laughter]
stupid okay so back to germany and
it's uh winter of 2020 you made a
mushroom ring
i like that that's cool put your finger
through it does it tell you
if you have coronavirus the only problem
with that ring is there isn't mushroom
[Music]
but i can be a fun guy
[Applause]
and that's all the mushrooms no more wow
all right so
in germany they are preparing for uh
the winter of 2020 and so just like how
we have uh
a like a renewed lockdown and curfew
they also have that too
in russia germany or russia
i mean whatever country you just want it
whatever plug and play they want to stay
inside in russia too
but yeah so they're imploring their
citizens to be heroes
and uh you get a cape uh no heroes come
in all shapes
why does he look like my grandpa uh
because he this this is the future so
they made an advertisement to
get people to feel you know
patriotic for their country to to to be
a hero for the country
and to help curb the uh swag for people
that
like do the right thing cool i think it
would be incentivizing yeah
so instead of a stimulus check we should
just get a little sticker
now we're not gonna give you so but yeah
here's one sticker at least
here's the advertisement for winter of
2012 oh read it
i think it was the time of the winter of
2020 when all of the eyes of the country
were on
us
[Music]
i just turned 22 studied engineering and
chemistries
when in the second wave i've arrived
chem
chemistry 22 at this age you want to
party
to study to get to know new people and
all that
going for drinks with friends it's a
good german accent maybe inflections
yet fate has different plans for us
different plans for us
that's young him an invincible danger
threatened everything we believed and
yeah this is some production suddenly
the fate of our country was in
our hands
we mustered all of our courage and did
what we was expected of us
the only right thing we did
absolutely nothing being as lazy as
raccoons
day and night we kept our asses at home
and fought the spread of the virus
that's literally me right now our sofa
was out front
and our patience was our weapon
[Music]
you know sometimes i have smile to
myself when thinking about this from
time to time
this was our fate this is how we become
heroes back then
during that corona winter of 2020. they
saluted each other
[Laughter]
yeah that's cute that's funny become a
hero too
that's cool yeah it's really cool they
took the whole like you know world war
ii
um and he was in germany um you're like
he's watching netflix and [ __ ] i like
the commercial that was dope
that made me think like what are you
going to tell your grandchildren about
this time
you ask about when they're learning
about coronavirus you know in school
right or whatever like 2020
oh that was the year my grandpa or my
grandma
when all the toilet paper was getting
corded i hear it's gone again
it is my buddies were telling me they
went to go shop for something they were
all gone hey if anybody needs any so
steve predicted that there would be
another wave and so he was
on he went to costco and bought like
this again
yeah but this time i didn't complain
about it because i was like all right
maybe yeah i'm gonna buy some also we
have a bidet from our sponsors yeah
that's been helped that helps to tell
bidets pretty like help yeah
they do help yeah i still need toilet
paper to like
i'll give you some five dollars a roll
everybody you just
paypal me i'm also invested in paypal so
it helps my stuff
nice double dipping i don't know i have
too many hobbies i feel like
people i i can't really like you're not
you're not watching tv
i'm so busy all the time though that's
uh i could never do that
that was me in like the middle of like
from when
it was the beginning to where we are now
in the middle time
that was me with animals animal crossing
definitely yeah that's different
yo people love animal crossing like the
pandemic actually started at the perfect
time for
our lives because we had just moved into
our new house two weeks before lockdown
so that whole beginning time was just
setting up our house and it was like oh
[ __ ] our house is like kind of
done like now what do i do oh [ __ ]
animal crossing because you
yeah and gina you know why because it's
like it
it's decorating you're like doing
interior design stuff without having to
spend a bunch of money
and like do your own house so i went
from interior decorating to interior
back to interior decorating because now
i'm doing it again you know i actually
strangely miss
your animal crossing days because the
music would just be isaac says the same
thing on it
there's like a soothingness to like the
music and like just knowing that you're
playing that i'm like
okay so you didn't you didn't hop on the
edible crossing no i would never
she has a house i made him a whole house
do you have an island and [ __ ] or what
you can't do nothing in there man no you
it's only one island per switch so we
only have one switch
but he has his house on our island yeah
you have to share the island but you
have
your own house but it's the most
pointless game you don't ever have to
play it yeah yeah
you're just all my wife's friends are
trying to get her to play do you want to
fight
it's so fun i love the music it puts me
in a happy mood trying to not get laid
ever again i got hella jealous because
watch a dog you're gonna be in the in
your own house
i saw influencers that got spawned like
some of our friends got sponsored by
animal crossing i was like what the hell
did
are you serious we were obsessed are you
serious we promoted animal crossing for
free
like every single video did you guys
email the brand
no no no
[Laughter]
we're not thirsty [ __ ] listen
to us okay we're recognizing promoting
the brand that we love
okay we both have like i love starbucks
we both have island tours to go watch
our island yes we do go check out on our
channel i don't think my island looks
like that anymore it's probably like
hella filled with weeds i have so many
weeds i bet
i want to come over here you have to
like actively pick your weeds in the
game yeah yeah
oh [ __ ] you can make stuff out of them
yeah it's like real life tend the garden
make out of your weeds you can attend
this garden they they teach you about
this is great
interesting at home off your mortgage
mushroom season right now
joe there's mushroom seasoning to stay
at home and enjoy
the lockdown this takes about two weeks
of time
it's perfect yeah two week lockdowns
yeah and you get to eat them in real
life
in the animal crossing i can't eat them
yeah yeah
yours is sprouting my inspired sooner
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
you